we are about to be forced to complement
each other on camera well I just named
it this is really awkward to think about
that's not weird at all
Max and I do give each other compliments
a lot this is the opposite of what we're
used to doing we're making eye contact
huh you're really great with people I
think you have a lot of joy in you and
it's pretty infectious okay Martin think
this would be the sorry can you just
look the other way okay I look over here
the other way all right feel like we're
doing wedding vows
Caleb's personality is rock solid in
conflict he's honest and there all the
time and you have great gravitas thank
you is that a compliment you know you're
very Susie a stick you are a very deep
thinker ah I like that a lot
that counts as person that was great
your personality it's very bubbly Zac is
that shining bright light we're like
kindred dry spirits
Hey
just we've got great biceps I think I've
like openly told you that it's a really
classic kind of beauty in space you have
a decent face really symmetrical
features look at him look at him ladies
what's not to like your eyes are two
colours which I like right they really
I've seen you with your shirt off and
you are more fit than you appear on the
outside of your clothes that's what I'm
going for
yeah it's got a great upper body and a
great jawline when you can when you can
see it and your smattering of body hair
also makes you more manly looking it
smattering well I'm gonna go out and
we're gonna like hit on some ladies you
bring Max's like the bringer I think you
have really great posture a very
attractive man I mean I'm looking at
look at this face just in please my butt
was clinched the entire time it's a
little weird that's it at first a little
uncomfortable but uh we ease into it
there's that male thing it's like it's
weird that you shouldn't do that that's
good it does feel good
we're just gonna trash out each other
call guys out there should go and
complement their guy friends right now
we should do this more often because
sometimes you're down you know sometimes
sometimes we get we get down on
ourselves
I think Eugene is very straightforward
and I really appreciate that and uh that
co-worker and a friend
I guess Andrews my friend now I guess
we're friends